Hello everybody! My name is Markipleeaoww
I bit my tongue, I really did.
Ow~
Welcome back to 'Reading Your Comments'.
Ba boop be de owowow
[Kaboom]
'Mark! The popcorn is coming to eat you! Run while you still can!!'
OH GOD! NOT AGAIN!
[Mark's out-of-shape huffing]
B1: Gonna eat ya, Mark!
B2: Gonna eat ya!
B1: We're coming after you!
B2: We're gonna eat ya!
[incoherent banana noises]
B2: RAAA-we didn't have the popcorn costume BUT WE'RE STILL GONNA EAT YA!
'If an apocalypse were to occur, who would you bring as your survival group and why?'
Well, I'm gonna bring the Survivorman, Tom Hanks from Castaway
and then Tom Hardy as Mad Max
Because I wanna survive! It's an apocalypse!
Screw my friends! I'M ON ME OWN!
That doesn't bode well for my friendships. But oh well!
[Yandere-chan voice] 'His hair reminds me of Josh Dun.'
Are you saying it would look good?
ON YOUR WALL!?
[Regular voice] I don't even know who Josh Dun is.
Hang on, I gotta look it up.
I still don't know who that is.
He's apparently the singer from 21 Pilots.
I don't, I don't know if I've even heard a 21 Pilots song.
Oops. Ooppsie poopsie!
Opps! Moving on! *Before the enraged fangirls come after me!*
'What's your favorite super herl show?'
??
[Announcer voice] And welcome back to the 2016 Vomit Olympics!
We-ohhhh.
[Gross sfx]
BLEAUGH
'Mark! I have an important question for you.'
Wasted opportunities~
A life's full of wasted opportunities~
'Would you like us to comment our Mario Maker levels to you so you can play them?'
Absolutely I would! I would love to play you guys' Mario Maker levels.
I'm sure there are already some out there that I can't find
because the searching system is a little broken in Mario Maker
but I like playing you guys' Happy Wheels levels and Turbo Dismount,
I would love to play you guys' Mario Maker levels as well.
You can comment down there, but it might get lost.
'Hey Mark, I live in LA too. How do you like living here?!?!?!?!?!?!?!?!'
'POOPERSTAMPER'
[dubstep beat drops]
'Oh. My. God. I just realized that Mark has- wow this is a crazy- a...'
'Knife up his ass?'
Yes!
Alas!
My life was betweext with shame
when doth Buttstabber
Er, when doth Stabber of Butts
doth... did...
corner me in a dark alley and then stabbed me-
with a knife-
up my butt.
With a knife.
Up my butt...
If you guys don't know about the Crazed Buttstabber, I'll put a link to a video...
ThERe??
Where you can watch my bizzare, rather absurd intro to a video
where I talk about a weird butt-stabbing maniac.
kewl??
'SING FOR US DAMN IT'
NoooOOOOO*crack*ooo~
[Kablooie]
'Will you marry me?'
[high-pitched] Noooooooo~
[Kapow]
'Mark you should show us pics from when you were a kid'
Well, there's only really one picture that tells the tale of when I was a child.
Or maybe two.
This is when I was a young lad,
very young and full of hope.
And this is me mid-puberty.
Boy, what a difference that time in my life made for me!
Aren't I glad that I went through that without any horrible disfiguring ailments?
Anyway... that's me as a child.
'So close to 12 million!'
Yes! We absolutely are and that is...
mindblowing. It is absolutely incredible.
12 million! That's almost too many people. That's...
It, it, it's astonishing to think about because holy crap!
12 million people! That's more than the pop-
I, I make that comparison all the time, but it's more than the population of some countries.
And... it, it's really humbling when I think about it
because I just came back from Cincinnati and I saw all my friends
and you know I saw them and I remember,
you know I was at my mum's house where I first started my YouTube channel
and I remember all the videos that I made there
and it's weird because I can remember, like, every single video
and when I go back in my channel, I can remember like...
the mindset that I had at the time that I was recording those videos.
And that's really cool because it shows the progress that I've made
and it also helps me remember that I'm just as stupid as I was back then
but for some reason, you guys continue to support me
and I'm grateful for that every single day.
Thank you all so much for being there with me
And I have a very special video
for 12 million that's going to be made by the end of the day today
whenever I doth hit it.
It'll either be later tonight or early tomorrow morning
but either way, thank you everybody so much for all the support that you have given me.
It is amazing and you are all incredible
and the amount of good that we've been able to do with this huge community is...
something to be proud of.
So you guys should be really proud of what you've done
and what we've done together
and just, thank you for being here.
So that's all the time that I've got for Reading Your Comments today.
I'm sorry for the shorter episode, but I have to go to the doctor.
I hurt my knee trying to run outside.
Which, lesson learnt, I should never ever go outside
or do anything physical ever again in my life.
I will hurt myself.
And generally in life!
I'm too stupid to survive in the normal human society out there.
So stay indoors!
Indooooors~
Indooooooors~
INDO*cracks*OOOORS
So thank you everybody so much for watching
and thank you for taking the time to write comments down in the comments section below.
Even though they don't make it into the videoes,
I have a great time reading through as many comments as I'm capable of.
So please, if you have something you want me to read in the next video,
write it down in the comments below!
And thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always,
I will see YOU in the next video.
Buh-bye!